[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo et pour cette émission un
j'accueille trois eurodéputés fait
d'abord cristian dan preda bonjour vous
êtes député européen de roumanie membre
du groupe parti populaire européen la
droite et une partie du centre ici au
parlement européen merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation face avoue christine
robot d'allonnes bonne foi bonjour vous
allez députée européenne française du
groupe des socialistes et démocrates ici
au parlement repères en france vous avez
été élu sous les couleurs du ps vous
êtes depuis un mois présidente de la
délégation socialiste française ici au
parlement européen merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et enfin marie
christine vergiat bonjour vous êtes
députée européenne française de la
gauche unitaire européenne en france
vous avez été élu sous les couleurs du
front de gauche merci d'être venu alors
notre premier sujet le sujet d'actualité
nous emmène en roumanie depuis une
semaine des milliers de manifestants
dans tout le pays contre un décret qui
assouplit les lois anti corruption
entre temps et face au tollé le décret a
été abrogée mais rien n'y fait la
mobilisation se poursuit
les manifestants veulent le départ du
gouvernement
une mobilisation d'une ampleur inédite à
la plus importante depuis la chute de
ceausescu regarde et on réagit juste
après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis plus d'une semaine les mêmes
slogans des missions voleurs honte à
vous des centaines de milliers de
roumains qui occupe le centre de
bucarest mais aussi des grandes villes
de province ils réclament la démission
du gouvernement
on veut que ça change
il faut réparer les erreurs la classe
politique ne doit plus nous voler ni
notre argent ni notre avenir
on en a marre nous sommes prêts à faire
de la roumanie un pays propre pour nos
enfants et pour notre avenir
l'objet de leur colère un décret qui
prévoit de condamner toute personne
conduit mais seulement à partir de 44
mille euros détournés
l'homme qui est la cible des
protestations c'est lui le premier
ministre social-démocrate soaring grimde
à nous accuser de vouloir faire amnistié
ses amis face au tollé il a fait marche
arrière dimanche dernier oui mais demain
on fera en urgence une réunion du
gouvernement pour abroger ce décret pas
suffisant la mobilisation se poursuit
chaque nuit
en près de 30 ans depuis la chute du
régime de ceausescu
la roumanie a déployé des efforts
considérables sur le chemin de la
démocratie et de la bonne gouvernance
ce décret ce n'est comme un retour en
arrière on voit parmi les manifestants
beaucoup de jeunes ce qui est normal car
ils sont plus prêts à militer quand ils
trouvent une cause dans laquelle il
croit et une classe moyenne urbaine qui
vit d'une manière relativement descente
pour laquelle les valeurs sont
importants cela ne veut pas dire que les
personnes pauvres souhaitent qu'il y ait
de la corruption ou qu'il n'y a pas de
mécontentement en province on a vu des
manifestations dans d'autres villes
aussi des sittings chaque soir des
dizaines de milliers de manifestants
rassemblés sur la grande place de
bucarest pour rappeler aussi que leur
pays des membres de l'union européenne
depuis dix ans et que l'état de droit
n'est pas négociable c'est la
mobilisation la plus importante depuis
la chute il ya près de 30 ans du
dictateur nicolae ceausescu
[Musique]
la question à cristian dan preda que se
passe-t-il en roumanie un décret en
question a été abrogée mais la
mobilisation faiblit pas mais parce que
vous savez la mobilisation c'est pas une
mobilisation partisane c'est pas un
parti c'est pas les partis d'opposition
qui mobilise c'est simplement une sorte
de lever
comment dirais-je et désorganisée
parfois chaotique et c'est vraiment
similaires à ce qu'on a vécu en des 189
moi j'étais étudiant à l'époque quand je
descends dans la rue maintenant c'est
les mêmes attitudes c'est le même esprit
le pan de 229 à la chute de la chute
dans le communisme vraiment très dur et
très autoritaire et non le point de
départ de cela c'est une question un peu
folle parce que le je trouve que le chef
du parti socialiste a été condamné et il
est aussi impliqué dans plusieurs procès
il ya aussi une soixantaine de députés
sur les 450 qui ont des problèmes
judiciaires et qui d'une manière ou
d'une autre ont été protégés de la levée
de l'immunité était bloqué par leurs
collègues dans ces conditions là le
premier ministre et il prend la décision
dans la nuit deux d'effacer par
ordonnance d'urgence par ordonnance au
gouvernement des délits qui ont été la
base des condamnations dont on parle et
en particulier de changer de parti et de
bloquer la possibilité de condamner pour
corruption des élus locaux nationaux et
c'est bon légende et c'est inacceptable
chez l'un c'est vraiment le
enfin le maximum de l'arrogance de
comment dirais-je du manque de
responsabilité c'est pour cela qu'on a
eu dans les rues cinq cent mille
personnes
c'est du jamais vu dans notre histoire
moderne avancer on n'a jamais eu cela
même en cas de 29 ans n'avait pas ces
foules non c'est un mouvement qui qui
qui sera je passe décisive qui va peser
sur la roumanie d'aujourd'hui et de
demain surtout le chef donc vous disiez
le premier ministre qui veut aider ses
amis alliés style ses amis donc le chef
du parti socialiste roumain liviu
dragnea c'est du même bord politique que
que le vôtre est une ordure d'allonnes
alors oui il est socialiste et démocrate
ne s'est pas pour autant qu'on va
combiner cautionner ce genre d'attitude
évidemment on est absolument contre
toute forme de corruption et pour la
transparence et pour l'éthique en
politique donc on ne peut pas cautionner
ça et si vous regardez le débat qui a eu
lieu en plénière la semaine dernière à
strasbourg sur la situation roumanie et
nous ce que nous avons demandé c'est
qu'il y ait un débat sera en commission
des libertés civiles
mais quel que soit le parti politique
auquel appartient gouvernements partout
en europe
ils doivent respecter l'état de droit
est ce le respecter à eux mêmes c'est
intolérable en france on a mis des lois
sur la transparence et en même temps on
va pas dire qu'on est meilleurs que
d'autres
quand on voit toutes les affaires qui
sortent à chaque canard enchaîné on a
des nouveaux épisodes d'affaires de
corruption aussi en tout cas de
suspicion de corruption
donc on a vraiment besoin et pour les
citoyens européens c'est fondamental de
d'être éthiques et de se respecter à soi
même ce qu'on impose aux citoyens
européens sinon comment voulez vous
continuer à avoir confiance en la classe
politique et qu'on pense que finalement
il n'y a rien de bon dans tout ça on a
cette obligation cette exigence voire
même d'être encore plus respectueux de
l'état de droit que ne peut l'être tout
autre citoyen marie christine vergiat le
décret prévoyait de condamner toute
personne corrompue mais seulement à
partir de 44 mille euros détournés
on peut comprendre la colère des romains
oui bien sûr et
rejoint tous ceux qui condamnent la
corruption je me félicite
qu'effectivement nous ayons eu un débat
la semaine dernière en plénières
auxquelles personne ne s'est opposé ce
qui est une grande première dans
l'histoire du parlement européen cela
dit moi je suis pour oui je suis pour
que chaque fois que l'état de droit soit
menacé
on est un débat serein sur ces questions
en plénière préparer en commission des
libertés civiles parce que c'est comme
ça que nous devons travailler
je regrette que nous n'arrivions pas à
le faire pour des pays
very enfin n'arrivons pas à le faire
véritablement pour des pays comme la
hongrie et comme la pologne où il ya de
vrais problèmes de l'état de droit
notamment sur les questions judiciaires
et sur les questions de la liberté des
médias
c'est tout aussi important moi ce que je
sais pourquoi je plaide c'est la même
position pour tous les pays quelles que
soient les partis politiques qui sont au
gouvernement et j'aimerais bien que
l'ensemble des coteaux politique soit
sur la même position pour tous ces
sujets dernier en date monsieur urban
vient d'ordonner le droit de tirer à vue
sur les migrants en situation
irrégulière
je m'étonne que nous ne soyons pas
capables de condamner ce type de prise
de position qui est une peine de mort
déguisée par un gouvernement européen ce
qui me paraît tout à fait scandale et on
va revenir à la corruption à si la
roumanie a s'est métamorphosé en élève
modèle de la lutte anti-corruption a
sous la pression de l'union européenne
et le magistrat un très offensif
le rapport de l' ong transparency
international publié fin janvier indique
quand même que ce pays est l'un des plus
mal classés 1 au sein des 28 s'agissant
du sentiment de corruption des citoyens
dans leur quotidien la corruption en
roumanie c'est un sentiment c'est
toujours du concret aujourd'hui
cristian dan preda écoutez je crains que
on a eu nos manies maintenant
complètement différent de ce qu'elle est
et non seulement 89 mais aussi à 10 ans
parce que je crois qu'il ya très peu de
pays au sein de l'union européenne où
vous avez des condamnations a
l'impression qu'on a quand on regarde le
reportage et quand on entend les
manifestants oui mais quand même il faut
voir aussi ce qui a été fait c'est à
dire aux nains je crois
en prison plus du nécessaire pour faire
un gouvernement et donc c'est vraiment
tous les partis c'est pas seulement les
socialistes et madame déjà et la région
c'est pas une question de la filiation
partisans qui nous fait lutte et qu'on a
droit de cheyrou à gauche donc
maintenant c'est justement parce que la
gagne et ça parce qu'on a vu que si tu
es en politique tu es quand même
condamné pour avoir volé c'est parce
qu'on a eu ça que les gens croient
vraiment à 1 avenue différent parce que
le niveau de la corruption
ça a été suite justement au malheur du
communisme communistes mettant en
lui-même un régime où tout est et
corruption au niveau de la classe
politique
suite à cela on a eu quand même des
forts avancés avec beaucoup d'efforts
avec des institutions notamment la
direction nationale anti corruption avec
des juges qui sont indépendants qui ne
sont pas sous la pression d'un parti
politique et donc c'est cela qui qui
donne espoir à tous ces gens là parce
que c'est des gens dans la nuit qui
expriment aussi leur espoir d'avoir une
autre une autre élite politique une
autre à notre comportement des gens
c'est pas simplement pour dénoncer c'est
des gens qui sont fils yeux mais qui ont
aussi les spas et ça c'est formidable
dans le contexte actuel qu'on a un euro
pour on ne va que déception catastrophe
a lancé intéresser des gens qui ont un
espace et c'est pour cela que j'ai dit
en plénière si les roumains ont su
mettre ceausescu à sa place ils vont
savoir aussi mettre ces gens la drague
madrid uns et les autres à leur place
ils sont très forts que les romains vous
savez alors selon le dernier rapport en
europe les mieux classés parle de
corruption sont surtout les pays
nordiques
elle est moins corrompus les moins bien
qu'à ses classes et c'est plutôt le sud
à l'italie la roumanie la bulgarie la
grèce
est-ce que la corruption c'est pas un
terreau favorable au populisme sauf que
quand on regarde ce qui se revendique du
populisme ne sont pas forcément exemples
de corruption
et ça ce serait bien de le rappeler
aussi et moi je vois encore une fois je
reviens sur l'actualité en france mais
il ya des traitements un peu
différenciés selon certains candidats
qui ont les mêmes problèmes concernant
des emplois fictifs
la pétition est l'assistant convention
et et corruption et les partis qui se
revendique du populisme parce que mais
le peuple n'appartient à aucun parti
politique par définition on fait tous la
politique pour défendre nos citoyens
donc déjà ça je récuse totalement mais
ils ne sont pas absolument exemples de
pratiques qui sont condamnés
condamnables et condamnées par la loi
et ça c'est valable partout en europe de
chez ces parties là aussi moi je crois
que la roumanie comme la plupart des
pays de l'est reviennent de très loin
que
la chute du mur et tout ce qui a suivi a
conduit à des gabegies épouvantable la
privatisation des biens publics a
conduit à de l'enrichissement personnel
massif
donc oui la roumanie a mis en place un
arsenal juridique intéressant qu'il
pourrait peut-être servir de base à
d'autres pays comme vous l'avez comme
vous l'avez dit néanmoins il reste des
efforts à faire en roumanie mais aussi
dans beaucoup d'autres pays et c'est
vrai que de ce point de vue il ya une
cassure entre l'europe du nord les pays
scandinaves notamment et le reste de
l'union européenne la relation à
l'argent des politiques n'est pas là
même si on ne serait pas possible
l'affection ne serait pas possible la
roma n'est pas ce qu'on peut pas donner
de l'argent
c'est une loi comme assistant
parlementaire à sa femme mais veut fils
c'est tellement ça serait partagée sur
la danse et régal chais pas légal donc
au parlement européen non plus
d'ailleurs juste un an
je vous propose je vous propose de
passer maintenant à une autre partie
magazine le droit à l'avortement un
droit fragile en europe à travers le
monde
47 mille femmes meurent chaque année des
suites d'un avortement clandestin dans
l'union européenne seuls quatre pays sur
28 interdisent totalement l'avortement
même même la houle ivg est légal ça
n'est pas simple exemple en italie chez
l'avortement est légal mais jusqu'à 70 %
des médecins se disent objecteurs de
conscience et refusent de pratiquer un
ivg avec des conséquences vous allez le
voir souvent dramatiques le reportage de
françois molins
[Musique]
en italie l'avortement est légal depuis
près de 40 ans comme en france c'est un
droit dont toute femme dispose pendant
les trois premiers mois de sa grossesse
mais ça c'est la théorie en pratique
70% des gynécologues italiens refusent
d'appliquer la loi ici à rome se sont
même 80 % des médecins qui se disent
objecteurs de conscience par conviction
religieuse
giuseppe noia et leur chef de file dans
son bureau
alignés comme des trophées les photos
des femmes que le spécialiste a réussi à
dissuader d'avorter aux fans qui
viennent me voir je leur explique ce que
c'est que de perdre un enfant
tous les problèmes de dépression
qu'elles vont rencontrer ça ce sont des
données scientifiques objecteurs de
conscience c'est faire preuve de courage
et de cohérence scientifique
le médecin est là pour donner la vie pas
pour donner la mort ce discours
copie conforme de celui de l'église est
répété également dans certains hôpitaux
de la capitale financé par le vatican
l'avortement thérapeutique y ait refusé
ce qui conduit parfois à des situations
extrêmes s'il arrivait à cette femme
valentina minuzzo 32 ans enceinte de
jumeaux et qui a perdu la vie
en octobre dernier elle entre à
l'hôpital de catane
elle souffre d'une septicémie provoqué
par la mort de l'un des jumeaux mais le
personnel médical laisse la jeune femme
mourir à petit feu sous les yeux de ses
parts on a prié le gynécologue toute la
famille avec moi de libérer ma fille
7 puis sortir les deux enfants d'atr
enlevé l'est ça fait des heures qu'elles
s'ouvrent et qu'elles crient lui me
répond devant tout le monde
il y a encore indiqué me bats à
l'intérieur et en tant qu'objecteurs de
conscience je ne peux rien faire et il
est parti ils ont tué ma fille personne
faire dès qu'on doit y ans nous dire un
mot de réconfort pour envoyer une fleur
ou ma femme
ces gens là sont des assassins le cas de
valentina miloud zoo à mobiliser les
associations qui veulent que le message
de ces parents soit entendu silvana
agathe ornais est l'une des dernières
gynécologue à pratiquer l'avortement
dans la région de rome
menacé de mort traîner en justice
elle estime qu'aujourd'hui toutes les
femmes ne sont pas à égalité face à la
loi
si les femmes sont riches probablement
qu'elles peuvent trouver une solution en
italie les femmes de la classe moyenne
partent à l'étranger et pour les
personnes à bas revenus eh bien elle se
débrouille
souvent elles arrivent à l'hôpital avec
des complications d'un avortement
clandestin et pour toute réponse le
gouvernement a fait passer une loi
désormais si on apprend qu'une femme à
avorter clandestinement
elle écope d'une amende de cinq à dix
mille euros
ça ne va faire qu'aggraver les choses
le ministère de la santé escamote le
débat et préfère mettre en avant le
nombre d'avortements en baisse une
logique que dénoncent certains élus mais
même les parties les plus à gauche sont
embarrassés par ce débat est vide
simplement c'est extrêmement difficile
de pénaliser les objecteurs de
conscience car on touche là à l'éthique
et aux convictions personnelles au fond
d'avis à ce qu'il faut c'est que l'état
prenne les choses en main et protège les
médecins qui applique la loi m'a dit il
faut dire clairement notre pays que
l'avortement est garanti et qu'il n'est
pas seulement limitée à une partie de
notre population
le conseil de l'europe a d'ailleurs
sermonné l'italie pour cet accès inégal
à l'avortement qui pousse de nombreuses
femmes vers la clandestinité
maigre consolation la pilule du
lendemain peut désormais être obtenu
sans ordonnance sans avoir à passer sous
le regard inquisiteur des médecins
[Musique]
aulas reportage de françois gaulin
christine revault d'allonnes le cas de
valentina mais lucho vous inspire quoi
elle meurt à 32 ans enceinte de 10 cette
semaine tous les médecins qu'elle a
consultés avait refusé un avortement
thérapeutique
ça m'inspire on repart sur le débat que
nous avions juste avoue le respect de
l'état de droit la loi la loi qui fixe
en italie malheureusement pas dans tous
les pays de l'union européenne encore
malte et l'irlande interdisent
l'avortement la pologne aussi mais en
italie c'est autorisé et pourtant des
médecins ne tiennent pas compte de la
loi qu'ils doivent faire appliquer parce
que leur conscience leur religion
l'interdît
c'est absolument scandaleux en 2010 est
d'en être là et d'en arriver à des morts
deux femmes et je crois fondamentalement
et je sais que ça fait débat et je sais
que les groupes de la droite ici enfants
s'y sont fortement opposés mais il
faudrait que ce droit à l'avortement
soit un droit fondamental européen c'est
un droit humain pourquoi les droits des
femmes ne sont pas dans les droits
humains
et pourquoi ça ne devient pas un droit
européen fondamentale qui seraient
garanties par tous m la question de la
religion la liberté de croire ou de ne
pas croire c'est du domaine privé et ça
doit être absolument respectée mais
c'est hors en dessous de ce que de ceux
qui participent des lois j'étais à malte
le week-end dernier nous avions une
grande convention sur la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes la
convention d'istanbul que l'union
européenne devrait signer et j'ai
discuté avec les ong de défense des
droits des femmes elles ne peuvent pas
dire qu'elle demande l'avortement à
malte sinon on leur coupe leurs
subventions
il est interné où l'avortement est
totalement interdit voilà il n'y a pas
de circonstances atténuantes
tous les partis politiques sont sur
cette ligne là et
les organisations non gouvernementales
qui se battent pour les femmes et qui
les accompagnent dans ce que vous aviez
décrit en italie pour aller se faire
avorter dans d'autres pays parce que la
réalité est là et il y à des femmes
qu'ils doivent pour des raisons
thérapeutiques ou parce qu'elles
n'auront pas la possibilité de garder
cet enfant
elles vont le faire mais dans des
conditions sanitaires qui sont
déplorables c'est scandaleux en 2017 non
être là mariton marie-christine road
l'échelle marie christine vergiat ya
aussi l'aspect économique
on l'a vu dans le reportage plus on est
riche que c'est facile de d'avorter plus
on est pauvre être plus on se met en
danger leur revenir à la situation
française la loi sur les vg a été
amélioré mais dans la législation
française
il y à une objection de conscience une
objection de conscience spécifique à
l'idéal ivg les les associations de
femmes françaises se bat pour que c'est
à cette objection spécifique al ivg
puisse être supprimés puisqu'il ya une
objection de conscience pour général
pour les actes
médicaux et on a de plus en plus je
rejoins ce que vous m'avez dit sur la
question économique des médecins
français qui se cache derrière
l'objection de conscience pour ne pas
pratiquer des ivg
parce que les vj's ne rapporte pas ça
rapporte pas assez et je trouve ça
particulièrement scandaleux
la question c'est de faire respecter le
droit arrivé j'ai en france comme en
italie nous ne sommes pas dans la
situation italienne je ne veux pas faire
de caricature mais le droit à l'image et
régresse en france il ya plus d'une
centaine de centres ivg qui ont été
fermés dans notre pays donc il faut
aussi regarder ou balayer devant notre
preuve devant notre propre corps et la
question c'est de permettre le respect
de lives et j'ai l'exemple italien que
nous avons vu tout de suite là est très
parlant en la matière on a laissé mourir
cette femme parce que le médecin mettait
en avant son objection de conscience
entre le petit coeur qui bat dans le
foetus comme le disait
le rapportait le père de cette jeune
femme qui est morte et la vie de la mère
ils ont choisi le petit coeur du foetus
moi ça me rend folle
finalement les mois sont morts les deux
mais tout est en mouvement c'est les
trois malfrats sont arrivés samedi en
prennent à l'avortement c'est un sujet
sensible en roumanie
c'est quoi votre position d'abord n'ont
pas écouté
c'est plus un sujet de débat parce que
on a eu une interdiction de l'avortement
de chasse en sept ans 89 20 ans et plus
dans le communisme en 89
ça a changé complètement et on a
maintenant une société qui est très
libérale de ce point de vue tout le
monde respecte le choix d'une femme
d'interrompre la grossesse il ya des
petits groupes qui comptait cela mais
c'est vraiment c'est ultra minoritaire
c'est bon vous pouvez pas avoir une il y
a un bon maintenant vous savez manager a
ici au palmarés au point il ya des gens
qui ont l'initiative des choses folles
et qui sont ultra marginal
donc maintenant l'espagne moi je vous
décris l'atmosphère générale c'est une
société qui était tolérante
moi personnellement je suis sur cette
position très libérale c'est vrai qu'au
6 2 le jeune femme cjrd allemand c'est
pas une obligation d'apporter mais ces
données exactes il ya au sein de notre
politique de débat on n'est pas dans
notre famille politique ni d'un côté ni
de nantes c'est l'une des questions qui
ne sais pas allez on passe au fact
checking de la semaine la contrebande de
tabac a coûté 11 3 milliards d'euros aux
pays de l'union européenne en 2015 c'est
ce qu'a déclaré à noro députés tchèques
alors vrai faux c'est notre rubrique
checkpoint préparé avec minutie par
thomas millions
le tabac n'est pas seulement un problème
de santé publique l'eurodéputé tchèque
tomas special ce qui a récemment déclaré
que la contrebande de tabac a coûté 11,3
milliards d'euros aux pays de l'union
européenne en 2015
comprenez une perte fiscale de 11 et 2 3
milliards d'euros
alors tout d'abord quelle est l'ampleur
du trafic de cigarettes illicites selon
l'office européen de lutte antifraude
environ 4 milliards de cigarettes
illicites ont été saisis en 2015 il ne
s'agit là que de la partie visible de
l'iceberg
seuls 10 % du trafic total seraient
découverts chaque année
cela nous ferait don au total 40
milliards de cigarettes de contrebande
mais quel est le manque à gagner pour
les étapes là accrochez vous le calcul
n'est pas simple tout d'abord rappelons
que sur le prix de vente d'un paquet de
cigarettes légales c'est l'état qui
gagnent le plus fan d'ac site au minimum
60% documents mais aussi à travers la
tva on peut pas dire les accises
les états membres ont reçu pas moins de
cinq ans que depuis hier devant deux
lutins pour atteindre 490 bulgare btv
racheter le quart de ce bref tout ça
pour dire 40 milliards de cigarettes
correspondent à 7,5 milliards d'euros de
recettes fiscales potentielles avec la
ventes de cigares ou de tabac à rouler
on arrive à 10
euros partis en fumée à cause de ce
trafic c'est d'ailleurs l'estimation
européenne officielle depuis plusieurs
années impossible d'être plus précis
puisque par essence est contre banques
et clandestine entre cette estimation
est celle de thomasz des choses qui il
n'y a qu'un pas 11,3 milliards d'euros
c'est probablement une réalité
[Musique]
et bien voilà c'est la fin de notre
émission merci à vous tous trois d'être
venu ed avoir débattu avec nous merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis à la semaine
prochaine ou retrouver nos ramadi à
cette même place d'ici là bonne suite
des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires bail
[Musique]